all right will fuller year by year he
had been getting better and better he'd
been getting healthier this year he was
having his best season he had a great
performance last thursday against the
detroit lions on thanksgiving now he is
done due to a ped suspension that will
extend into next year here's his
quarterback deshaun watson talking about
whether he wants the impending free
agent back in houston in 2021
we all love him he he always do the
right thing and that one slip up just
got popped but
you know hey we always gonna have his
back you know will's my brother the
whole organization knows that too and
you know make sure that we get them back
for next year um especially in this
organization but that's a whole other
story on topic since you touched on it
how important is it to you
if you can if they can make it work to
get him back here next year
oh for sure yeah i mean that's very
important so
definitely one guy that i'm gonna be
working on this this this this last
month and all season for sure
you know i i i haven't nailed this down
to the level where i want to write a
story about it at pft
and and it is unfortunate that every
time someone gets pop for peds chris we
hear the dog ate my homework type excuse
right i took a supplement that was
tainted or somebody told me it was okay
there may be something to this idea that
that that the doctor told him it was
fine i still don't
think that
the professional athlete should take the
word of anyone disconnected to the
league or the nflpa but there may truly
have been an element of truth to this
it's just unfortunate because every time
except for julian edelman whose position
was i don't know what happened every
other guy offers up the same version
of
i didn't do it on purpose i didn't cheat
you know what the details vary but the
message is the same
i didn't deliberately cheat right i
didn't deliberately do it somebody
spiked my supplement yeah from the gnc
or something this or something that it
wasn't me trying to get an edge by
deliberately taking a banned substance
yeah i mean listen
like you like like i've said many times
i i don't have you know
a soft spot in my heart for this type of
stuff i don't i just i'm not for it you
know cheating's cheating i don't know
any way to say it oh great you're going
to take a drug and get a competitive
advantage over other people and
also maybe endanger other people because
you're bigger stronger and faster than
you should be
also endanger yourself because you're
bigger faster and stronger than you
should be it's just i got nothing for
you there i don't you know i got nothing
to say will fuller
if they want me to believe it like i
said then show me the medical record
until then i don't care i don't care put
it on twitter everything else goes on
twitter these days oh show me the i
don't know but that i'm not gonna
believe it i don't know if i'm gonna say
it i know desean watson likes him and
all that stuff and i'm sure wants him
back but you know it's his friend and i
don't know what the people expect them
to say there either
we've had guys in the past who will huff
and puff about filing lawsuits in
situations like this
and and hey if will fuller sues this
doctor and the evidence comes out and it
really is consistent with what he's
telling us
right it may take a while but that may
be where we're headed
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports